j'ai publié ce lundi un article dans le
fanage là-dessus
et
ils ont
c'est je crois pas que ça
visite à Pékin
et vient un bon moment donc c'est trop
tôt et
il y va et ce qui importe c'est quand
même de transporter et prendre des bons
messages et les trois messages qui sont
à mon avis centrales c'est sécurité
européenne c'est
la priorité première
allemande et européenne c'est à dire si
la Chine si la Chine commence à
aider la rue si d'une façon beaucoup
plus significative qu'actuellement par
exemple en livrer en livraison avec des
livraisons d'armes
ça devrait avoir des conséquences
immédiates pour la relation Europe
Chine relation économique Europe Chine
donc on peut pas accepter que la Chine
est la Russie ça c'est le premier
message qui devrait livrer deuxième
message
toutes les questions
de commerce et investissement sont des
questions à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne c'est l'Union européenne qui
est responsable pour le commerce et pour
les investissements et
l'Allemagne ne peut-être pas accepter
une politique chinoise
qui essaie de diviser l'Union européenne
par exemple comme la Chine l'a fait avec
une cohérence une équation économique
contre contre la Lituanie c'est
inacceptable il faut il faut travailler
ensemble c'est l'Union européenne qui
est qui négocie sur le commerce et les
investissements avec la Chine
troisième message
[Musique]
c'est aux entreprises les entreprises
devraient être prêt
à une excellation d'une des tensions
géopolitique entre les États-Unis et la
Chine et entre l'Europe et la Chine donc
c'est-à-dire on peut faire du commerce
avec la Chine mais il faut être prêt en
tant que entreprise que
cette cette commerce s'arrête d'une
façon assez rapide s'il y a une
musculation des tensions donc c'est
quand même management Dieu politique
[Musique]
il faut gérer ce risque géostratégique
au niveau au sein des entreprises et ça
c'est un message qui devrait être très
important donc j'espère que le chantier
a allume mon article dans Le fenêtre
mais à mon avis c'est des messages
centralité européenne gérer la
confrontation géostratégique et
[Musique]
la sécurité européenne est une priorité
par rapport à la Chine un grand merci
[Musique]